Okay. So welcome to the show, Rachel. Thank
you for dedicating some of your time to
sit down and have a conversation with me.
For the people listening at home, could you
tell us a little bit about you?
Sure.
So, yeah, my name is Rachel Sweeney.
I currently work at Book Technology. I've been
in the Kubernetes space for a number of
years now. And,
yeah, I live in the Maryland, Washington DC
area. Happy to, you know, dive into how
I got where I am today, but live
here with my wife.
Live on a boat about four months a
year. I like having an eclectic lifestyle.
So, yeah, I have a lot of varied
interests.
I mean, I could sit and talk about
living on a boat for four months of
the year for the next couple of hours,
but maybe that's a session for another day.
You said you've been in the cloud native
Kubernetes space for a number of years now.
What what led you to to where we
are today with this terrible mess of Kubernetes?
Like, what's your experience when why were you
unfortunate enough to end up in the Kubernetes
space? I always looked down on the Kubernetes
space, and I've I've had so much fun
in it. You know? It's it's tough. Right?
So I wanna know what made you the
engineer you are today and how you ended
up here. Yeah. It's a great question. So
I
did not have, I guess, like, a traditional
IT background.
I got a degree in Chinese history.
I worked as an executive assistant for a
number of years, and I spent a lot
of time, like, liaisoning with our board of
directors and kind of learning how, you know,
companies work, how you get value, and stuff
like that. And I'd always been big into
computers since I was probably three or four.
You know, I started programming when I was,
don't know, 12 or 13 and taking apart
and rebuilding computers and doing all that, like
trying to install Linux. And I knew that
I wanted to get into tech space professionally.
And as soon as I discovered the whole
DevOps philosophy and movement, it just immediately clicked.
I was like, there's so much value in
this, and it's just, you know, how do
we make things more efficient and just, like,
string together pipelines,
you know, orchestrate containers, and all that good
stuff.
And I very quickly went down that rabbit
hole of just, like, how do you use
things like Docker or Ansible and Chef and
got into Kubernetes and CICD pipelines.
And I was, fortunate to get a job
working at the Pew Research Center.
And when I was there, I was, essentially
the only DevOps engineer type person. We had
a data science engineer that did a lot
of, you know, stuff you would expect with
data science engineering.
And there was a lot of overlap with
his role into DevOps. And we knew that
we wanted to migrate to Kubernetes because we
were having some, I guess, scalability issues with
data collection. So
I, you know, took on the work of
figuring out, like, how do we deploy Kubernetes?
How do we migrate workloads over to it
and all that good stuff?
And after doing that for a couple of
years, I ended up going to Fairwinds,
which is a Kubernetes
centric
company.
You know, part of Fairwinds is focused on
consulting and standing up clusters for clients who
are new into that space,
and that's initially where I started as an
SRE.
And from there, it was, like, you know,
helping stand up clusters, making sure they're working
well, and how they should be handling a
lot of, like, ad hoc requests. Like, how
do I make sure I can, like, track
a client source IP all the way through
to my application
so it doesn't get lost in network address
translation,
stuff like that.
And, eventually, ended up on the,
the software as a service side of things
as a tech lead where I was, you
know, working to help out with our SaaS
product to get best practices in place for
a lot of our clients.
So, you know, we had a platform that
would surface up a lot of different information
in your clusters, whether it's, like, security or
best practices or costs.
And so a lot of that was, like,
helping clients install Falco in their clusters so
that they could get all that information
surfaced in one area or, like, how do
you right size workloads and all these different
things.
And then finally, you know, I'm I'm now
at Built Technologies as the tech lead to
migrate,
our stack over to Kubernetes
for a lot of various different reasons.
And so, yeah, that's kind of been the
journey that's gotten me there, and it's just,
really just following a lot of interest as
I dive deep into the Kubernetes rabbit hole
and, know, realize all the friction along the
way or the things that are the gotchas
that you need to know about. And, yeah,
it's been quite the journey.
Awesome. Thank you for sharing. It's funny because
as you were talking about all that, there
was a meme that popped up on Twitter
just this week that kinda
it it feels really familiar to the story
you're sharing. And it's the meme of, let's
adopt Kubernetes and there's a little logo. And
then the next bit of it is, like,
and here's all the stuff you need after
it. And there's, like, the Helm logo, the
Argo logo, the Flux logo, the Falco logo,
the PEXI logo. Like, just this this sort
of tools that we have in the cloud
native landscape because, unfortunately, just doing cube admin
in it is, like, step one of many,
many steps that you need to successfully run
and operate a Kubernetes cluster. Quite a pickle,
I think, we're in these days. So if
you could tell me about the challenges you've
seen with people adopting Kubernetes. Yeah. So some
of the challenges that come up with adopting
Kubernetes are, you know, there are a lot
of unknown unknowns, I guess, if you're not
in the Kubernetes space. And, you know, some
good examples of that are things like you
know, I could list off a a lot
of different phrases that you might not be
aware of if you haven't been in Kubernetes,
but, like, how are your pod topology constraints
configured?
And if you've never heard that before, you're
just like, what on earth is that? And,
you know, it's something that you can configure
behavior
to
make sure that your your workloads have as
much uptime as possible to be more resilient
in case, you know, certain sections of infrastructure
go down.
There's also things like, you know, what are
your image pull policies,
your network policies.
You know, going from Docker to Kubernetes,
it's actually less restrictive in terms of syscalls,
whereas I think Docker want blocks something like
a 28 syscalls and Kubernetes is probably in,
the sixties or so. And so if you're
making that migration,
are you aware of that? Do you know
that maybe you should be locking down some
more of these? And if so, why? And
just, you know, needing to know all of
those as you configure the behavior for the
platform.
And there's, you know, plenty of other things
like pod disruption budgets. And so I think
all of those things are the, like, steep
learning curve of Kubernetes where it is a
platform that will do exactly as you tell
it to. It will behave as you configure
it to, but you have to know how
to configure it. And so that knowledge gap
is often something that a lot of companies
struggle with.
I think there there used to be something
more of, like, you know, should I do
self hosted or managed? But I think for
most people in the cloud,
managed is a, you know, a way that
a lot of people go since it has
matured a lot, and there are reasons for
self hosted. But
and then, yeah, just going back to that
skill set piece where your developers now are
deploying to this platform, and do they know
how to configure
things if that's something that they're working in?
And, like, how much awareness do they have
for Kubernetes?
You know, I know at at Built, we
have a lot of, education material available for
developers.
So as we make this migration to Kubernetes,
they're going through initially, you know, courses on
Pluralsight, now in Udemy, and, a lot of
great YouTube videos that you put out and
just kind of, like, learning all these pieces
and what they need to be aware of
and going from there.
So I think those are a lot of
concerns that
you should be aware of going into it
and prepared to answer. Yeah. It sounds like
there are two key things there I picked
up on. It's it's one of them. It's
like almost everything in Kubernetes is some sort
of toggle or a bit of configuration.
You know, like you said, down to the
topology spread constraints. You've got disruption budgets. You've
got limit ranges. You've got quotas. You've got
do you wanna do seccomp filtering?
Endless, endless, endless, YAML, endless, endless, endless options.
And unless you have seen some stuff before,
I don't know. Like, do you even know
what half of these options are? Like you
said, the unknown unknowns. Like, if if I
had never had to configure these things before,
then they're just out of sight of mind
as well even though they exist. So that
again, that's maybe part education problem, but then
part you don't know these things until you
need to know them as well. Right? Like,
top of the head question here, you can
just say yes or no. But can people
be successful with Kubernetes by just having a
12 line deployment dot YAML with their image
in it? Like, how far is that gonna
get them and how deep do you need
to go to then? I guess it's a
scaling problem. I don't know.
Yeah. I think with,
just about everything in tech is it depends.
You know? It depends on, like, the complexity
of what you have and, like, maybe you
can start off slowly just like if you
know you want to move to Kubernetes, you
do just throw one thing up there in
the cluster and see how that works.
It it seems like there are a number
of of strategies for, like, organizations shifting to
Kubernetes,
whether you, you know, outsource it to have
somebody stand up a cluster for you and
make sure you have that, like, rock solid
foundation,
or maybe you hire a consulting company to
come in and get your knowledge gap, to
kinda close that so that you can deploy
things quickly to Kubernetes.
Or maybe you do just hire engineers that
already have those skill sets.
And so I think, you know, depending on
the scale of what you're doing and,
what you're trying to accomplish with Kubernetes, you
know, it really just depends. And, honestly, if
you if you don't have a ton of
scale or you don't have a lot of
complexity in your applications,
then, you know, maybe consider why are you
thinking about Kubernetes in the first place. Because,
like you said, there are so many toggles,
and it's kind of like, if you have
a startup and you have a very simple
use case, you're not just gonna, like, hop
in a fighter jet and, you know,
toggle every single switch when, like, a simple
plane would work to get you to your
destination.
Hopefully, that analogy made sense. But, yeah, like,
maybe you get to the point where you
need all the toggles, but initially, probably not.
Yeah. I mean, I think you're 100 right,
and the analogy is great. You know, I
take it a step further. Like, you know,
if people need to travel 60 miles down
the road, go on a train, not even
a plane before you jump on a fighter
jet. Like, the Cloud Run and Lambda can
get you substantial amount of the way depending
on the complexity of your application. But, yeah,
you're right. Like, it's it's definitely a a
fun problem. And I'm gonna kinda just talk
about clustered for ten seconds here because
what I thought was interesting is you said,
I said you could have 12 lines of
YAML. You said that could get you so
far. And I think we're both on the
same page there. And then you mentioned that
you could bring an external help, right, like
a company to help you with that migration
to Kubernetes.
And I was thinking in my head, if
you give a company that hasn't seen Kubernetes
before
a 300 line deployment YAML. And let's assume
as an example here. Right? There's a pre
stop hook that does a sleep for thirty
seconds. Now if you know what that's there
for, great. Right? But if you don't, it's
probably the first thing you're going to delete
and say, well, that's the purpose. Like, I
don't need why am I doing this sleep
for thirty seconds? That's ridiculous. Let's move it
out. But if people have seen clustered before,
they know that pods actually don't really handle
failure that well and the pre stop can
actually give you enough time for NGINX to
handle the connections that are currently in flight
before they get moved through. All these edge
cases. Right? Which is why I say clustered
is a great show. People should definitely go
check it out. But I don't know these
things from operating Kubernetes clusters and production. I
know these things from clustered as well. And
I think that's
a really cool way for people to learn.
Yeah. I'm gonna plug myself. I hope that's
allowed within the first five minutes of the
show. Yeah. I I mean, having been on
clustered, thoroughly enjoyed it, like, wonderful learning opportunity
and certainly watched a time just to, you
know, level up my own Kubernetes knowledge because
so many guests just have such creative ways
of bringing the clusters to their knees and,
like, could happen to you accidentally.
You know, you hopefully won't have somebody in
your cluster just, like, you know, toggling everything,
you know, in a a negative way, but
good to know.
Alright. So you've mentioned migrations a few times,
and that's a part of your new role
where you're working at Bell. So what I
I'd love to dive into is just
if you're happy to share information on what
the current landscape is and what your path
migrating to Kubernetes looks like, then, hopefully, we
can dive into that in a bit more
detail too. Sure. Absolutely.
So, yeah, it's funny when I when I
first interviewed at Bilt, one of the questions
I actually asked our one of our directors
was like, you know, why Kubernetes? Like, it
is so hard. Why do you actually wanna
migrate to Kubernetes? And, you know, a lot
of people will migrate for scalability issues and
stuff like that. But,
one of the the big reasons for us
moving to Kubernetes is that we started off
with a monolithic application as many companies do,
and it just, you know, became fairly complex.
And we started to break it down into
microservices.
And now all of those microservices,
they have their own dependencies in terms of
other microservices.
Each microservice has its dependency in terms of,
like, maybe they need a queue in the
cloud, maybe they need, like, a Kinesis stream
or a Kafka cluster or something.
And so with all of these
microservices being broken down and having all their
their dependencies,
there's a a certain amount of complexity that
has grown in, I guess, the the way
of simplifying. You know, simplifying things makes them
more complex, but more bite sized in a
way.
And so we ended up with custom internal
Python tooling
to manage these complexities.
And so we you know, for example, we
have one custom internal Python application that takes
care of deploying a stack of infrastructure to
a different environment,
whether it's like a staging environment,
production environment, or demo, and it takes care
of, like, all the secrets and config changes
across environments,
making sure all these pieces are where they
need to be, you know, running Terraform. It
does some Docker building and stuff. And that
has
you know, in that situation, it solved some
of that complexity, but now it's kind of
all been pushed into a Python app that
if you are not working at build, you
don't know how it works, and you kinda
have to come in and, you know, put
things into there. And when things grow or
slowly shape in a different direction, you now
have to write more code in order to
be able to support that.
And then the, I think the thing that
kind of triggered the Kubernetes migration is the
complexity of those applications
got to a point where
developers were no longer able to do development
on their local machine.
And so now if you need, you know,
n number of microservices, let's just say 10,
it's like a small stack you're working with,
They all have all these AWS infrastructure pieces.
You know, where do you do that development?
And in our case, we have another internal
Python tool that stands up a, essentially, a
virtual machine and, you know, provisions everything you
need. All of the the Terraform is there,
and all of your, containers are being run
there.
And that Python app has just been,
I guess, time consuming in terms of the
number of tickets that it's created for helping
developers when things start to break or, you
know, some developers don't use it anymore because
it's complex and it has its issues. And
so
that's something where, you know,
we're
this Kubernetes team is helping developers move faster
since we want them to release features to
our customers as fast as they possibly can.
And right now, this developer environment is slowing
them down, and it's something that we can
solve.
And so with migrating to Kubernetes,
we are able to package up a lot
of that complexity in things like Helm charts.
We're also bundling it with cross planes. So
if a microservice needs, you know, five different
pieces of infrastructure in AWS,
it's all packaged in that Helm chart. And
so now you can,
kind of just build the collection of Helm
charts that you need where you can say,
you know, I need j, k, l, z,
y, and b. Those are the microservices I
need. And if you, you know, deploy them
all at once, you're gonna get all of
the infrastructure that you need. We've got it
set up in a namespace for developers, and
then they're using,
you know, DevSpace to be able to
do development as if they were doing it
locally. And so for us, that has been
for the developers that are on there right
now, like, it is a a huge time
saving effort even for the ones that were
able to do development locally, which is quite
surprising.
But that's been, yeah, that's been the big
push to migrate to Kubernetes at Build, and
it's been going great so far. So Nice.
What I think is it's interesting there is,
like, from the people that I've spoken to
in the past, like, when they're moving to
Kubernetes, it's generally because of, like, microservice service
adoption and they've got all of these containers
and they need some sort of orchestration.
But it sounds like the journey that Bel
Air on is kind of actually a bit
more twofold. You know, it's kind of part
taking legacy code, breaking it down, making it
more maintainable and moving forward.
But also the self-service
platforming side of it, like, given developers that
ability
to have a cross plane resource, get a
Kinesis thing and get ups that along with
the code that they're shipping. I mean, that's
just a really strong enabler for teams. Right?
And like you said, it allows them to
deliver features to customers quicker. And I think
that's a one of those understated things with
Kubernetes. It's it's normally all all we have
containers. We have operational complexity. Let's do that.
But, actually, if you do it right with
the right people and you build a platform,
is you you give a really strong foundation
for companies to iterate and evolve faster than
their competition. Yeah. That's a great point.
And thinking too about how, you know, we're
creating new microservices every single month and being
able to support that. You know, if we
automate a lot of that to where Home
Chart just gets created and, you know, the
cross plane APIs are already there, we don't
need to be in the loop for these
developers. And there are going to be cases
where they always are going to need us
in the loop. But if we can get,
like, 80% of the developers just self-service, like,
that is such a powerful thing for getting
features out to customers as fast as possible.
One other thing I might add,
really quickly is,
you know, one of the the situations we
had with our custom internal Python tooling is
a lot of the orchestration
of containers is something that we were building
into that into that Python app and things
like how do you handle
end to end encryption with things like MTLS.
You know, we've rolled our own version of
that, but now we have to maintain it
and support it. And it's been really fun
seeing the Kubernetes ecosystem grow up and mature
where there are so many off the shelf
solutions
that people used to have to code their
own solution for.
And so it it does seem like, you
know, if your company is spending more and
more time coding custom solution for things that
could be just had off the shelf with
Kubernetes, like, maybe that's the time to take
a look and see, should we be migrating
to this since we have these complexities that
are growing? Awesome.
Just because you talked about how the Kubernetes
communities, they're they're evolving, they're producing software. Like,
the MTLS one is a great example. Right?
You know, Linkerd came out and just said,
hey. Run us in your cluster, and you
get automatic MTLS for free, which is is
wonderful.
So, you know, kind of diving in on
that a little bit, like, the CNCF landscape
has dozens, hundreds of projects depending on how
deep you look. Are there three to five
off the top of your head that are
just a must have installs for all Kubernetes
clusters? Yeah. There are so many things in
the ecosystem,
you know, from, like, edge case things to
common core things.
And I think some of the big ones
that most
people are gonna start to encounter is, you
know, do I deploy these things to Kubernetes
clusters?
What does my CICD pipeline look like? You
know, maybe if you had a, CD tool
before,
it's
may work well with Kubernetes. It may not,
but tools like Argo CD and Flux are
two great ones to take a look at.
You know, they're designed specifically for deploying to
Kubernetes clusters. And so those are really big
ones that are gonna help with just all
kinds of things even if you want things
like, you know, blue green deployments or canary
deployments or just how you configure that behavior.
You know, they're gonna help you support stuff
like that. And so those are things I
think that most people end up looking at.
Another is how do you actually deploy all
of this YAML that you have? You know,
you're quickly you're just gonna become a YAML
engineer as there's all these toggles to set.
And do you want to package that up
in something like Helms that you can, you
know, version it, release it, and just have
all of these, you know, defaults set in
place? Or do you wanna use something like
customize so you can just patch and override
certain values as needed?
Those are two things that, I think most
people are gonna encounter as well.
There's so many other things out there. Like,
another one which I think is really cool
is just tools like
you know, it used to be things like
the like, horizontal pod autoscalers and stuff, and
you still do have that. But tools like
KEDA are really cool where you can, you
know, scale out depending on, like, the depth
of your queue size or something, or there's
just so many custom triggers for when might
you want your application to scale out. And
I think a lot of people
will probably end up encountering and using something
like that. And if you're not in Kubernetes,
you know, how do you solve that issue?
Going back to that ecosystem thing, it's like,
do you end up coding your own version
of Keta that you then have to maintain?
And so that's a really fun one that
I enjoy as well. Awesome. Alright. Let's dive
a little bit deeper into the migration story
then.
So how far into the Kubernetes migration are
you with built at the moment? Yeah. So
we are,
you know, we've been working on migrating
developers over to the Kubernetes cluster, and we've
got, you know, over a hundred different microservices
that we need to deploy. And so we've
started kind of tackling them one at a
time and just figuring out, like, what are
the best practices that we want for this
these different applications and how do we deploy
them?
And we've got our clusters. You know, we've
got these environments stood up. We have a
bar for, you know, what do we need
to do in order to bring developers onto
it? And then separately, what do we need
to do for it to be production ready?
And so a lot of those production concerns,
we're not focused on them just yet since
our our biggest bottleneck is how do we
get developers as productive as fast as possible?
And so we've currently got one full team,
I wanna say about 30 developers on it,
and, you know, it's already saving them. I
think, like I think they said there was
something in particular that took seven minutes, and
now they're able to cut it down to
one minute. And it's just, like, something that
happens every single day across these 30 developers.
And it's just become part of their daily
workflow where they could do development locally, but
they're all working in Kubernetes because it is
a lot faster. And we are also onboarding
another team in the coming weeks. We're gonna
work with one of the senior engineers there,
make sure his stack looks the way it
should and acts the way it should, and
then slowly roll it out to the rest
of the developers.
So, hopefully, over the next few quarters, we'll
just be migrating all of the developers over.
And then as we're doing that, building out
automations that we don't have to manually
do this every single time of converting their
application into a home chart and all that
and, you know, kind of scripting out what
does that translation look like from their application
being deployed in ECS before to now being
deployed in Kubernetes.
And so, yeah, currently in that process of
migrating developers over.
Okay. So
the old system was container based on ECS.
You've now built this platform. You're encouraging people
to come over and deploy to Kubernetes.
You know,
I I don't wanna say, oh, it's easy.
They're already on containers. Right? Because obviously, there's
all the devil's in the details with all
of these things. So what have been some
of the main challenges that the developers have
experienced as you bring them across to the
new Shiny?
Yeah. I think,
I guess there's a couple. So
one is,
you know,
what is the incentive for them to go
to Kubernetes or, like, why should they? And,
you know, in their old environment, it was
problematic,
some of them gave up on using it.
And then we had, like, a share or
we have a shared ops environment, and so
developers kind of take turns deploying their code
to that shared environment to test things out
and then roll it back.
And so from that standpoint,
you know, they
won't have to fight over resources anymore in
Kubernetes, and so there's a huge draw there
for them to get into into Kubernetes,
It's like a big incentive that they they're
ready for, they're excited for.
And then for the, you know, 30 or
so people that are in there right now,
I think, initially, a lot of it is
just knowing, like, you know, how do I
like, right now, we just have, you know,
ephemeral or not ephemeral, but we have, like,
MySQL running in the cluster. It's got, like,
an EBS volume backing it, so there is
persistence there. But it's still somewhat ephemeral. Like,
it's not like an RDS instance that's gonna
be there for a long time.
And so some of the things are like,
how do I access that? You know, if
I wanna do a migration, what does that
look like? And how do I get these
endpoints,
etcetera? Just like, how do I think about
how to do what I was doing before?
And then, you know, if I wanna deploy
maybe a different microservice or it's not behaving
the way I expected it to, how do
I reset that and stuff? And so I
know there was a sprint or two where
I just spent, you know, hours and hours
working on documentation to just try and answer
all of those questions so that they had
exactly what they need to, you know, self-service
themselves as much as possible.
And, you know, I think a few weeks
after onboarding those 30 developers,
it kinda got quiet, and it's like, does
that mean they're not using it? Like, what
does that mean? And I it's kind of
a good sign because they're they were using
it, and it was just kind of working
for them. And we'd have questions pop up
every now and then, but for the most
point or for the most yeah. They're fairly
resourceful, and I've just been able to solve
a lot of those issues once we did
that prep work of making sure that they
had everything that we thought they would need.
And then if they didn't, you know, we
added that to that that base of documentation
and tooling so that they were able to
support themselves.
Wow. So you actually provided documentation before migrating
people over? A bit of both. Yeah. We,
for a few like, we had some very
rough skeleton documentation for, like, the the brave
people that started it first, and then they
had, you know, 50 questions or so. And,
you know, we took that and kind of
just slowly
added that to the documentation so we didn't
have 30
people asking 50 questions and, you know, so
on as we onboard more.
Yeah. I mean, it's a it's a great
idea of what I should probably try myself
sometime, but I'm I'm always too keen to
do the engineering stuff and I'm always a
bit lax on the documentation.
A bad trait of my own that I
should definitely resolve at some point. I'm curious
about them.
You know, you've got these target developers on
the platform.
You used to do SRE.
I mean, are you the sole reliability
team for this cluster? Is that something you're
training up the dev team to do? Is
there another team that takes ownership of that?
Like, what does that look like within built?
Yeah. So we have,
I wanna say, 12 engineers,
you know, that typically do,
DevOps type stuff or, you know, follow that
philosophy. And so
the,
team structure recently is probably about five are,
you know, SREs focused on all of that.
And then I wanna say five, six others
are focused
primarily
around Kubernetes
and getting developers onto Kubernetes while also supporting
some of the traditional ways of doing things.
Most of the engineers
that are on that team that's focused on
Kubernetes and getting people over have come from
companies where they've worked with Kubernetes before.
So I don't think there might be a
a handful of people that haven't worked with
it before, but most of the people on
the team do have experiences at other companies,
big and small.
And so that has been, just amazing. Like,
they're wonderful people to work with, and they
have such amazing ideas that, you know, oftentimes,
I would never even have imagined. And so
it's it's been really rewarding working with them.
And I think the you know, roughly 12
of us are supporting those, maybe a 50
developers while we work up to this to,
you know, help them be more productive.
Wow. So do you have any tips? You
know, I'm assuming, you know, Kubernetes migrations are
something that a lot of organizations, a lot
of teams are are doing. Not all of
them are fortunate enough to have, you know,
a team of 12 or 15 people to
kind of help that be reliable and onboard
them. But I'm curious, like,
just because it's all at the top of
my head. You know, I'm working with a
company right now. There's just five developers. They're
migrating to Kubernetes.
The why is of doing that? That's another
story. We could touch on that later. But,
you know, they want like, if they wanted
some great advice that says, how do we
make sure that we don't destroy our own
cluster, destroy our data, deploying our own workloads
onto? Like, what are the safeguards that you
can encourage them to do as someone who's
been quite successful, it sounds like, with a
migration? Yeah. I think
probably just looking at, you know, what are
the best practices out there and what are
the the you know, there's so many good
articles and YouTube videos and thoughts about, like,
how to get started in this space
and just thinking about, like, what are those
core things that I need to be concerned
with and going from there. If it is
something that you are new to, then maybe
it is worth kind of just, like, dipping
your toe in in terms of getting stuff
spun up, making sure you're comfortable with it,
and seeing what that looks like.
I've always, you know, been fortunate, I guess,
to, like, reach out the community, and I
think that's a a huge thing that's very
helpful as well is make sure you are
engaged in the community.
I think we are very lucky to have
so many, you know, really smart people in
the community at our fingertips, whether it's on
Twitter, on Slack, on Discord.
You know, know when I found your Discord,
you know, to shamelessly plug that, but there's
just so many wonderful people in there that
if you throw a question out there, they're
happy to answer. And, you know, there's book
clubs you can join and stuff like that.
And so I feel like just, you know,
making sure that you are educating yourselves and
focusing on,
you know, a lot of those best practices
is definitely a good way to start.
And that's assuming that you are coming to
this new and you don't have, you know,
external people that are are helping out with
that. So
I think that's probably the harder way to
do it is just having internal people, like,
skill up without any outside consultation.
So
Yeah. I think that's really important.
The cloud native and Kubernetes
communities,
the code themselves, the projects. Right? They're they're
evolving constantly. Like, the Kubernetes and cloud native
today is not the Kubernetes and cloud native
of even three, six, nine months ago. Like,
everything is just the wheels are in motion
and maybe sometimes a little bit too fast.
So I I couldn't imagine trying to build
a platform without always keeping up to date
with what's happening, reading new books, watching new
videos. I I I just don't even think
it would be possible.
Like the Kubernetes APIs change fast. So, you
know, the project released. It used to be
for five times a year. It's now four
times. No. It used to be four times
a year. It's now three times a year.
Deprecations
as we're all aware happened second fast in
the Kubernetes landscape. So, yeah, I don't think
you can stick your head in the sand
and just say, we have a cluster. The
job is done.
It's just not gonna work that way. Yeah.
It's it's funny.
Every time I look at the
like, what are the new things in the
CNCF? I'm just, like, always blown away by
how many new ones are in there. And
you know, when we migrated to or when
we started, figuring out, like, how do we
want developers to work in Kubernetes,
there were just so many tools between, like,
you know, Telepresence,
you have Tilt, you have Dead Space, Scaffold,
just
so many tools on the scene just for
this one little area of how do you
solve this problem. Yeah, definitely a lot to
keep up with. Yeah. Definitely.
Alright. Let's flip that question around then.
You know? Sorry. How long have you been
at built? Been about maybe eight, nine months,
right around there.
Yeah.
I'm assuming that few things have maybe been
wrong in that time. Is there anything that
comes to top of mind that you could,
like, share? Like, any failure stories that we've
been able to learn from? Or has if
you just been extremely lucky and everything's been,
like, five stars all the way through? Yeah.
I think what's been challenging
is,
figuring out,
you know, which
there are so many options in the cloud
space and which one to go with. And
so we've gone through a lot of POCs
of trying all these different tools and seeing
which ones work best.
And sometimes it is hard because they are,
they both do such a good job at
what it is.
I think, also, when we first got started
with cross plane, you know, it's a there's
a lot to that tool, and, like, it
it has so much value in what it
can deliver once you get everything up and
running. But getting it up and running is
pretty challenging into itself, and that was something
that we struggled with for a bit where
we're like, you know, how do we do
this? How do we solve this and all
that?
And in that situation,
our manager, Jacob, he reached out to AWS,
and it turns out that they had a
program. You know, if you're in AWS to
essentially
work with a number of, you know, amazing
people, like, I think Carlos Santana and Christina
and a number of other wonderful people there.
And they helped us, like, get up to
speed with cross plane and how to like,
what are the best practices there?
How should we think about structuring this, and
what are the patterns that this will look
like? You know, we've come across this technical
issue. How do we solve it, or what's
the best way to solve it? Some of
it is challenging because it is, you know,
a fairly new tool, and so some of
the best practices are still being figured out.
But that's one where we probably flailed around
for a little while, and then, thankfully, we
were able to get some help from AWS
in that regard. And that's something that was
has been tremendously helpful.
I'm trying to think because I know it
hasn't been entirely smooth sailing. You know, there's
certainly things where, like, I wish we'd done
them sooner.
Some of those being, you know, more automation
around things, like getting home charts up and
running. You know, I probably should have done
that a little bit sooner, but some of
that also has probably just come from as
we migrate them over, we figure out what
we can automate and just kind of iterate
from there. And so,
yeah, it's been a lot of a lot
of hurdles for, you know, built complex
infrastructure.
Okay. Have you ever executed your disaster recovery
plan?
So we have,
for the ops side of things, we certainly
do. When I say ops, I'm just referring
to, like, our traditional, like, ECS,
custom internal Python for all that.
For the developer side of things, you know,
we've got those two bars of, like, what
do we need to get developers on board,
what do we need for prod?
And the prod threshold is where things like
the disaster recovery plan, you know, we certainly
need to have that in place and practice
before then. And so at this moment, it's
not as high of a priority as getting
the developers on board. So short answer is
no.
So
working with developers in the in the past.
Right? They're doing this migration to Kubernetes. Sometimes
it's a migration to containers.
Their old development environments have have changed. Right?
They don't just do composer install, a gem
install, a gem bundle, or a a pep
install. They now have all of these containers.
And if they're moving to Kubernetes, the chassis
either move into some sort of service oriented
architecture, maybe even microservice or arc microservice
oriented architecture.
The development environment gets a lot more complicated
to the point where working locally maybe isn't
an option anymore. So I'm curious
what is the setup look like and how
are you just handling that complexity about?
Yeah. So what we've got right now is
we have developers
that,
in the old environment, it would spin up
the entire stack of everything that you would
could potentially develop on it built,
and most developers don't need everything. Sometimes they
do, but not always.
And so in this new situation,
you only spin up in the cluster exactly
what you need.
So if you want to, you know, do
development on microservice
a, in order to do that, you have
a dependency of microservice like b, c, d,
e, f, and all of their AWS infrastructure.
And so but all you care about is
microservice a, and that's what you wanna develop
on. And so with that, that's where we
can spin up just that stack of resources
in their, namespace.
And then from there, now that they've got
all their dependencies in place, they're going to
want to do development on that microservice.
And using DevSpace,
as soon as they type DevSpace dev,
what it does when it kicks off that
script is it actually,
it starts off where, like, you know, you've
already got your home file installed for the
microservice that you want to work on, and
DevSpace is essentially just gonna, like, do an
upgrade install over that, and it's gonna put
some of its magic in there. And it's
going to sync everything that you have locally
that you define that you wanted synced remotely,
and it's gonna place that into your remote
container.
And so at this point, the developer actually
has the experience that it is local because
they can work in Versus Code or IntelliJ
or whatever they're using. And as soon as
they, like, make changes and save them locally,
it's gonna sync it remotely.
And then that way, they're able to test
their changes against all of those other microservice
dependencies,
and they can just iterate a lot faster
where they've got all this remote stack. And,
yeah, it just comes off as if it
is a, like, local environment.
Awesome. That's DevSpace by Loft. Right? That's the
same project? Yep. Which I think is in
the CNCF now. I wanna say they just
yeah. Yeah. I think it was donated to
the CNCF. That's awesome. Very cool. Yeah. It's
one of those things that I personally struggle
with. Development environments in Kubernetes is definitely challenging.
And I think we're really lucky right now
to have things like DevSpace and Telepresence and
Scaffold.
And I'm sure there's many more that I'm
forgetting. So yeah. Definitely awesome. We've covered, like,
challenges. We've covered some benefits,
things that you're getting things that went wrong,
things that are going really well. And I'm
just curious, you know, you're nine months into
this migration. Developers are being onboarded, so I'm
assuming the answer is yes, but I'll let
you go into more detail. Like, is this
a net positive
adopting Kubernetes going through the trials and tribulations
of having
services and containers and the cloud with all
this ephemerality?
It
build,
certainly. And, yeah, I think, obviously, that's gonna
vary from company to company, but the
complexity
is not going away, and it's only continuing
to grow. And so, you know, wrangling that
complexity
is just getting more and more expensive in
the way that we were doing things, certainly
around in developer environments.
And so by, you know, doing this work
now and allowing developers to have these environments,
they're able to move a lot faster, which
saves them time, gets more features out a
lot faster, and, you know, ultimately just helps
out with the the business value of, like,
why does this company exist?
It's to meet the needs of our customers,
and the faster we can create features for
that, the better it is. And so that
is a problem that it is, you know,
starting to solve today with a lot of
these you know, with the teams that are
on board.
And so I think that's just gonna continue
to pay dividends,
especially as it matures,
the platform gets better, and, you know, new
microservices come on board. Maybe we change some
of that architecture of how the apps are
configured. And, you know, with all of that,
just continuing to reduce the time that it
takes developers to get features out to customers,
this is certainly a net positive.
So
Wow. I mean, I kinda wanna end the
episode there because, like, that last thirty seconds,
so I'm by the CNCF should be paying
you for.
I'm getting royalties. Who's saying?
Alright. Well, thank you for sharing your story.
It's been really insightful.
And just learning about this migration, the way
that you're doing that. I love that you've
mentioned tools all the way through. I can
just imagine people sitting there writing these down
and going to check them out when they
get a chance. So thank you so much
for that. I'll now give you the opportunity
to plug yourself, your blog, your Twitter, your
LinkedIn, your company, anything you want. Feel free
to to share away. Sure.
Yeah. I guess the first shout out I
would give is, you know, just to Build.
It's been a, you know, an amazing place
to work with some incredible talent here.
Unfortunately, we're not hiring DevOps people at the
moment, but if an availability comes up, I
would definitely encourage people to reach out. And
I found that I've been learning so much
here recently, and it's just really fun. There's
so many great people to work with and
fun challenges, and so that's really allowed me
to thrive, and that's been fun.
Also, Fairwinds. You know, if you're entering the
Kubernetes space, Fairwinds has so many great open
source tools.
There's things like Polaris.
There's things like Goldilocks,
Pluto.
The list goes on and on. You know?
And whether you want to know best practices
or you wanna right size containers,
there's a lot of great stuff that Fairwinds
produces.
They also have a great SaaS product, you
know, if that's something that, you know, as
the complexity grows and you have many clusters,
how do you get visibility into that? There's
just a lot of wonderful things coming out
of Fairwinds to help people manage all of
that. And so, yeah, those are definitely things
I would encourage people to look into and
yeah.
Alright. Awesome. Well, thank you very much for
your time. I hope we speak again soon.
Have a great day.